I got a question for Rooney you play a
very strong female character which is
quite rare but there has been some
controversy surrounding you being cast
in a Native American role yes how did
that influence it didn't really
influence my performance at all I mean
there's been a lot of talk about that
and certainly when I had wanted to work
with Joe for quite a quite a long time
so when it was presented to me that he
wanted to meet with me I was like well
there's not really a part for me in it
and they were like no he wants to meet
with you for Tigerlily and I was like
well I mean that's not really possible
but you know I'd love to meet with him
anyways I love Joe and we sat down and
he explained his vision of the world to
me in it it just made sense he showed me
you know the collection of all the
images he had put together of how he saw
the native village and it just really
made sense to me you know in in the
original book Tiger Lee is not a Native
American that's something that was was
later put into the Peter Pan adaptations
but it's not actually a part of of JM
Barrie's story you know it's like joe
said it's um Neverland is is is Peter's
imagination and and we wanted the
natives in the native village to be
natives of Neverland and natives of as
Joe likes to say planet Earth
you